All right, here is our algorithm before for mean.
We're going to change this to work for max--max as it turns out is the name of my son
because I just find the stuff really important.
In the very deep sense, the thing for computing is functionally equivalent to the mean.
It's really very, very similar kind of calculation that's happening,
but the details are going to end up being a little bit different.
We're going to start off instead of the total of zero sort of a bit the max-so-far being
whatever the first element of the list is, and then, so we should make sure that we don't
compute that one twice then we're going to consider all the other elements in the list, and if
the element that we're currently considering beat the max-so-far, then we have a new max-so-far.
There can be only one and that's what we do, we just apply this task to every element to the list
keeping track of the max-so-far, and then, when we're done,
the max so far is the max-so-far of everything--woohoo!
Now, perhaps not surprisingly Python--you don't want to do this.
You don't want to write your own max routine because Python already has one,
but just as before, you have to be really careful when you use things like max in your programs
to keep in mind that this is a linear time operation--it's not constant time.